So much money. Yeah, I drove by the one in
I, it's Kinda like the silver lake area.
Hollywood man. They've got a lot
of money. Did you read going clear?
It's, there's, there's a lot of
what's, what's good about crazy,
what's good about crazy and about being
like if you have a fucking purpose in
life, man, it doesn't have to be
rational. But if you have a purpose,
if you've like a clear
directive in terms of, you know,
l Ron Hubbard says this and so I'm
just gonna listen and I'm going to push
forward and I'm going to stay positive
and I'm going to avoid the negative
people when I'm going to use all these
tools in order to maximize my performance.
All good shit work. Yeah. All
good. It could be to your thing,
some made up nonsense. And by the way, if
you read anything about it, by the way,
when counts around and start
saying, by the way, by the way,
you read anything about l Ron Hubbard,
they essentially think
that he was self healing,
that he was creating his bat shit crazy.
He was having me doing an inventory.
How his brain works.
Like that's what he did.
He took a detailed inventory over
many years of how, how every I'll,
how the minutia of his brain worked and
he really category, he cataloged it.
That's why a lot of some
of it, he borrowed a lot of
like old systems and stuff,
but some of it is,
I works,
I love you made everyone were
like navy fucking to help.
It's like the commanders
were like in AP fucking out.
But if you think about
Christianity focused the
European and American mind for a
long time,
everybody was on the same page and it
was very easy to kind of move things
forward as a uniform body. Nobody
kind of disputed what the truth was.
That's a recent Hubbard, I
feel like with Scientology, um,
I'm pretty sure they're signups are
going down because of research and with
everyone see org.
Oh my God.
Apparently that little design is cash the
front. Yeah, it is. What whoop your ass.
You get on the line now. Yeah.
He's beat the shit. He made
some shit up. Yeah, right.
Yeah. Like if you're like, oh, so I show
your hands down, just fucked up today.
Like beat your ass, kicked people's
ass. Apparently it was that.
Who was that said that David Miscavige
his dad. Is that his dad? His Dad.
And then also on the document talking
about how abusive and the book is crazy.
He goes into detail about David
Miscavige. Yeah, Tom Cruise kicking then.
I'm sorry, what was his dad's name?
Ron. Ron Miscavige. Sorry Ron.
He tie rod the podcast. Oh,
interesting. Made me sad.
It doesn't talk to his son. You
know that, that, that, that,
that's the thing that made me the most
sad that the dad and the son don't talk
to each other.
We over some nonsense.
The best thing I ever heard was, I'm a
guy I knew who was a teacher and he was,
had scientologist and had been
for 23 years and somebody said,
are you a scientologist? And he kind
of caught off guard and he said,
well let's examine that for a sec.
I've taken classes there for 20 years
and I've found enormous benefit from some
of them and some of them,
and I've paid money for some of
my found zero benefit from so, uh,
and, and I, and I put into practice
some of the cults, the, you know,
some of the courses and stuff.
So if that makes me a scientologist,
I guessed I am. It was kind of a
good answer. That's a very good deal.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean that's, there's, you
can get that out of a lot of things. Sure.
There's a lot of things that
are like that, that have
some nonsense in him. Yeah.
But I think people operate really well
when they have like a scaffolding,
like a structure that they
have to follow the Brit. Yeah.
And then they have a purpose.
They think there's a Po,
a positive action to their directive
and that there's going to be some grand
plan that they fit into
perfectly because of their work.
Know wrong with that either.
Listen, man, if that works for you,
it's bullshit until the contract breaks
out. But it's just if you bill, yeah,
right. Look at Leah Remedy.
I mean Leah Remedies,
she has the worst fucking
person over the [inaudible]
crazy man doesn't get off. She
doesn't give a fuck. And she's,
she likes being that girl that scared,
that's her. She likes that role.
It's almost like she was
designed because he like,
it didn't make sense that she was in
Scientology to begin with when I met her.
Right.
Because when I met she's like this take
no bullshit east coast chick and is also
beautiful. So I was like,
Huh, she's a scientologist.
I always got along with her always.
She was always very friendly but there
was always this like be careful don't
same thing. Stupid jokes.
Like all right, Jesus. Yeah,
I still the same way I had such
the same way she had so much power.
So here's the thing,
if she's got all this machine that
she'd just say about the book,
but she's got all this like she's got
all this like brass and the weight.
How does she get sucked into
that? Well, she was a little kid.
That's how she grew up in it. She got
sold a bill of goods and so she was like,
wait a minute, boy. They should have
kept her. But how does Tom Cruise? Yeah,
they live with Tom. I knew they
get, how'd they get Tom Though?
Like Tom wasn't that young. I
was very young. He was very,
how they get them and John Travolta.
Well I think people want
something that makes it look,
I bought the book I bought Diane,
I bought it through a late
night at 1994 son pre internet.
I was at home chilling and my apartment
in north Hollywood and I was like, damn,
this sounds like they're making a lot
of sense here and it doesn't make sense
the Laba,
but some of it does.
What are you 35 okay.
I'm 50 15 years older than you do.
You've got to think, you don't
really remember before the Internet.
You're like an infant. Yeah. Okay.
I was here as a grown man when the
Internet hit in 1994 but before that you
would get late night infomercials.
You'd be buying fucking squeegees
and Shit and pre selling.
I was pre cell phone bro. Yeah.
When I met, had a landline phone.
Now I know you guys were older,
but I'm just telling you this is dianetics
was something you'd see on late night
television and it was really compelling
because you can't do any research do it.
There was no Google, there
was no, there was no youtube.
Eddie Bravo would have been
his boss. Eddie knowledge. No,
but it's just what all of us.
No one really knew.
This is how a lot of things snuck through
this. You are curious all the way.
No, no, no, no, no. I never
went. We never thought,
we never thought that Arnold
Schwarzenegger or semester
salon or any of those
people were doing sterile shut the fuck
didn't I was seven and knew that before.
I knew they were doing stairs.
When I saw Rambo two I just thought
that was from weightlifting. No,
I knew it do steroids. When I was in
high school. I didn't think I didn't.
I didn't know that Hollywood, I didn't
know when you see demolition, man, I,
I just thought, I was like, dude,
how'd they get so fucking cut?
I've got to start working out. I
didn't know that. Right, right.
Maybe because I wasn't in the workout
world, but I mean I really, he's,
back then all of us were naive to
steroids. We run, the word is, fuck.
Here's the thing is, man, we,
you could find out like, okay,
what is Scientology based on? You could
find out, you could find in, okay,
does chiropractic medicine work?
Right?
You could Google stuff now and you can
look, okay, does fluoride cure cavities?
We didn't get,
we didn't get an answer,
but we might be able to get a sense
and you also get a sense of like,
here's the critics of Mercola,
this is what their perspective is.
Here's the critics of this natural
pathic site that might say some unfounded
things about vaccinations are
about, so there's always some, it's,
you can get a sense,
yes, but you, you lease,
you have a chance in 94 dude,
when I commend you to have a chance,
not a chance to Anthony Robbins cassettes.
I had a fucking vinyl
thing and you open it up.
I have all these different cassettes
and I would listen to those by the pool.
In my shitty apartment and room. Tony
Robin, didn't you get a lot from it?
I got a lot. Got a lot. He's
leaches. Fuck, I got a lot of shit.